I'm getting weaker physically but
internally I'm getting stronger and I'm
determined and certain to carry on till
we achieve this great goal for not just
Iranian people or the or the people of
Ukraine this who do these days get
killed by the irgc Drone which Supply to
Putin
I'm here I'm carrying this protest and
Hungry Shark for our fellow British
citizens because today we experience the
hands of and we see the hands of all
your GC here in London when Metropolitan
Police few weeks ago asked Iran
International TV station to relocate
from London to DC because of the threat
of irgc that means we are not safe here
because of the threat of irgc and I will
continue this